this show is brought to you by Club W
that's Club w
never come home to a wine-free house
again just go to clubw.com Joey right
now check it out clubw.com Joey to get
50 off of your first order that's right
Club W is offering our listeners 50 off
of your first order when you go to
clubw.com Joey this show is also brought
to you by meundies
go to meandies.com Joey right now and
choose from either a subscription of a
single pair or get 20 off of your first
order when you go to meundies.com Joey
go to meandis.com Joey check out all the
great t-shirts underwear socks all of
their great products when you go to me
on these.com Joey you're gonna get 20
off of your first order and the show as
always is always brought to you by
anna.com go to audit.com and use code
word search to get 10 off all of their
amazing optimization products like Alpha
Brain new mood and strong boom
View
s
[Music]
just when you thought it was safe you
went to church you were feeling good
about yourself
now the real Church shows up you
understand me Lee Syed Big John McCarthy
it's just a little thing on a Sunday
a little get-together a little Chit Chat
to get your Monday Morning Drive
on fire
[Music]
great out of the cause first album
bring back a lot of memories
who gives a [__] about memories I'm
saying
2016 [__]
what's happening gentlemen what is up
what's going on
Post St Patty's Day we got Big John you
know what I'm saying not that he's
selling I didn't celebrate
I never once did it in Boston I never
I'm not a big drinker I never once
they're open at like 10 a.m 6 a.m to
Jimmy go to a bar just to see the it's
like going to the zoo no I'm so much I'm
I'm that big of a nerd I never went I
now I wish I had gone to a parade or
something I just never to me the thought
of waking up at like 6 a.m and going and
drinking a beer just is the last thing I
ever wanted look just that I I wish I
could do that like there are people
doing whiskey 6am you wish you could do
that I wish I was that much of a man I
wish I could have destroyed myself that
fast I wish I could get up in the
morning have a whiskey and stuff for
breakfast or something I could never
even think of doing something like that
the craziest thing I did was one year my
buddies got together they had a bar
called Gregory seven day weekend they
rented a bus and they all got on the bus
and it was the craziest thing I ever saw
in my life and after the third bus stop
I said that's it I just left them there
it just you tapped you just it wasn't
even that it wasn't even about the
alcoholism or nothing it was just about
it wasn't me it was just too many people
too many guys dressed in green and I'm
like it's 10 in the morning people
drinking already you know one beer with
you with your steak is good for lunch
everything after that I don't know how
people survive it it was funny as hell I
saw it I went to lunch with my wife uh
Saint Patty's Day we just went through a
lunch and we walked past an Irish bar
and it was you know Studios thing it was
bad black people white people they don't
care Oh no you're all like that listen
man it's just an excuse to drink that's
it that's all it is like there's people
who can't wait for Saint Patty's Day
that's it dude we were going to
breakfast because there's this great
breakfast place out where we live it's
called Mrs Olson's man it's it's a
classic it's on Zagats and stuff it's
got great food and they're they just
moved to a new location and it's right
by this bar and we're going there it's
you know 9 30 in the morning whatever
and there's all these people guys God
damn Miss Olson is [__] going crazy
today no they're all going into the
lookout bar it's Saint Patty's Day
they're drinking already I go man
they're a lot better person than me I'm
too old for that [__] yeah I can't do it
no I never really did I got I got it I
understood you know it's just a good day
to get him but
I can't sit in a bar never was I a bar
guy do you know that I mean for about a
eight-month period I was forced to in a
way but I grew up in a bar my mom had a
ball growing up so yeah once I saw that
click in the daytime I used to go how do
people do this drink in the dark the
sunlight is out you know I could see
getting high amid at night that's fine
but in the daytime the sun's out you're
in a dark bar smoking cigarettes and
stuff what do you think we I don't I
think if I started at 6am I'd probably
be like 11 A.M I'd be done I don't even
think I'd make it to 11. you don't think
so I do I wouldn't I have a beer around
the southwest and I pass out on the
flight I have a you know they give me
those little business Select coupons and
I'm like why do I do it what's wrong
with me I'm going to Vegas let me loosen
them so for a year I would only drink an
Irish Cream like Bailey's Irish Cream on
Ice why would you do that that's just a
waste of time so finally I was looking
at the menu and I saw doers and ginger
ale
and I go you know what now that's that's
not bad with a guy like me drinks and
it's good for your circulation do a
couple acupuncture needles after that
you're brand new and I do that now every
fly and I'll do with doers and ginger
ale and pass out for the rest of the
flight and wake up a little [__] up
I know both of you guys spend a lot of
time in Vegas have you ever done like
one of the big cups that you have to
like wear like the 30 60 ounce slushy
alcoholic slushies any of those no no
and when you see those people in Vegas
you actually think from and I really
feel bad yeah yeah but you're gonna feel
like [__] in two hours with all that
sugar and all that booze you're gonna
feel like [__] this listen this if you
talk to old boozers they'll tell you
what like the who was telling us that he
went somewhere and that they drank
coconut water now with vodka it's no
hangover recipe
they drink milk with coconut water with
vodka no no hangover or something the
biggest thing to hang with man you're
dehydrated you dehydrated those sweet
drinks when I go to Vegas and I see
those girls those sweet drinks early on
I look at them and go well they might as
well have a Cosby cocktail because
they'll be done in three hours those
drinks will kill you that Sugar kills
you
know I wasn't cool enough for these
either but when I was growing up the
cool thing was scorpion bowls at Chinese
places oh that's tremendous I never had
one
people would drink those things while
you were on stage in every show you had
to walk over a puddle of vomit
it's like a little swimming pool oh my
God you ever see those oh yeah I grew up
in a place to My Thai and every Saturday
we go up there and four of us would get
the zombies on fire and you put the
straws in it you don't drink out of it
they're great going down too
Big John what's the story brother dude
I'm just having having the time of my
life man just enjoying life you look
good I'm doing good you're working a lot
I work too much yeah just about every
week this is your first weekend off in a
while yeah I had to take this one off
this is my uh my my dad's wife my
Stepmother's it was her uh 78th birthday
and so I had promised long ago that I
would take this date off because he was
having her family come out and our
family and so it was it was important to
them that they have the whole family
there for the most part the only person
that wasn't there was I guess it was my
daughter is in the military she's in
Alabama so she couldn't be there but
just about everyone else was so that
that made it a it was nice nice for them
it was a nice day to see everyone it's
nice sometimes just sit around with
family and sometimes on the way that
you're like what I gotta do this [__] as
you're driving on the freeway [__]
brother I'm gonna deal with that [__] he
still owes me 600 from three years ago
but then you get there and it's fine and
that's when you realize what family is
you just everything goes away you know
if it's
you said you loosen up you start playing
with your nephew or something that's it
and all of a sudden you have yourself a
great afternoon before this started man
we were rocking and rolling in here
about the point system the first thing
we were talking about was last night
with the Hector Lombard and Neil magnet
which you know
when would you recall that fight I would
have called it in the second round oh
the second round absolutely yeah the the
real thing is what people are looking at
you know a lot of people are going to
sit there but well why wouldn't you stop
in the first round because magni was
really hurt he was he was hurt and this
is you know our job is to try to let
those people get through when there are
hurt but they are still actively trying
to compete
when we talk about long ago at UFC 3 I
came up with looking I'm going to stop
the fight if the fighter cannot
intelligently defend himself
and you look at what happened in the
first round with Neil magni and Lombard
Neal was hurt but he was actively trying
to protect himself he was doing the
right things he's moving and that's what
we're asking of in the back when we talk
about you you hear us in like when we're
going to talk between two fighters
before our main event we say hey protect
yourself at all times we've gone over
the rules protect yourself at all times
nobody recommends all that stuff when we
say we've gone over the rules what we've
gone over is about conduct and what
we're looking for and what I'll tell the
fighter in the back is look at if you
get hit with a shot and it hurts you
similar to what it you know Hector
Lombard hit Neil in the shot it hurt him
you could see it and you get into a
position where this person is coming
down and they're attacking you and I if
I don't think you're defending yourself
in an intelligent fashion if you are
still able to consciously hear me
I'm going to be telling you and I would
tell Neil Neil move get out if you hear
those words move get out it's telling
you Neil if you stay with what you're
doing I'm gonna stop your fight
so what I expect of you is you hear
those words I want you to try to move
the position try to take away what he's
attacking you with show me that you want
to be part of the fight as long as
you're trying I don't care if you're
successful I care that you're trying as
long as you're trying I'm going to let
the fight go it's when you don't try or
you can't you're stuck in a position
that you can't get yourself out of and
you're accepting damage the fight's
going to come to an end well what do you
mean by uh defending intelligently
because there's times where they'll
still be putting their hands up or
something so what is where does the
intelligently or where does the line
come in when you talk about intelligent
defense you're talking about if a guy is
coming with heavy blows and you're
putting your hand up to the side of your
face we'll say and he's sitting there
with a heavy blow coming down on it it
doesn't matter that his hand is hitting
your hand because your hand is attached
to your head and what it's doing is it's
scrambling your brains that's what we
can't have but if you're doing things as
far as taking my hand and putting it up
and trying to move myself and just move
the position so now I make the person on
top of me alter what they're doing
altering they have to stop they have to
wait now they try for another shot all
of those things are someone who's doing
something in an intelligent fashion even
though they're accepting damage
what they're doing is they're fighting
intelligently
you look at that first round Neil fought
intelligently he was hurt but throughout
it he was going he was he he pulled
himself into guard he tried to get
himself back up he went back to guard he
did all the things that we look at that
were saying he is still in that fight
you get to the second round and Hector's
tired he he burned himself out trying to
put Neil away and then he gets hurt and
then he's in positions where now it's
different at the end near the end of
that second round he's got Neil on his
back he's what we call rear mount he's
got hooks in and if you look his legs
are up off of the ground so he has no
hips his hips are gone and all he's
doing is getting hit and he's in that
position where we'll say if you
hear me tell you move get out and you
don't try or you can't because of the
position you're in the fight's coming to
an end and that's why that would have
been the difference and why you stopped
in the second round and you didn't stop
in the first were you given any guy was
any of this guidance given to you by
like the UFC the athletic commissions
like where are you
I think that's my answer but I like that
that's beautiful you know that that
that's the whole thing is you know
now I teach classes and stuff and I try
to get people educated as far as why we
do things what we want to do and it's so
people don't make mistakes that I had to
make but you know I had to learn on my
own you know back when the UFC started
you know there was nothing like it and I
was the Pariah people looked at me and
you know the other referees from boxing
you know I was the bad guy so none of
them wanted anything to do with me I had
to I had to figure things out I had to
do I had to make a mistake look at it
say okay how did that mistake happen and
what can I do
to make this better the next time and it
was trial and error and so you know now
I go and I give that information to
every referee I can in MMA because
that's what's right for the sport of MMA
whether the the referee uses it that's
you know upon them you know I can't tell
them you know what they have to do I can
tell them this is what you should do and
this is why and then it's on them to do
the right thing
when
Neil Magby got hit in the second round
he went backwards and he landed right in
his guard I remember something like that
correct uh hected him like a straight
and he went backwards
sometimes a guy gets hit he hits the
canvas
and just by look at his eye or you guys
catch a little bit that he goes out it's
over like once he goes out just a little
bit you guys see that I don't see that
at home I don't have the eyes like it's
very weird that you knew
magni was doing though he was hurt but
he was just at home you were that
experience you could watch it on the TV
and you pretty much know I didn't know
at times if he was hurt or well when you
look at you know let's take a look at
that and and there's different types of
knockdowns and obviously there's a ton
of different knockdowns but I'll break
knock Downs into five different
categories all right and Neil magni had
the very first category when we have a
guy we can all fall backwards okay we're
not meant to go backwards we're meant to
go forwards as a human being that's the
way our body is set up but Neil gets hit
with a shot and he goes back but when
you see him falling down the first thing
you see as he's going backwards is you
see his hands starting to go backwards
with him and they're going backwards to
actually break the fall right okay that
right there tells you his brain is
connected he knows where he's at and it
doesn't mean that the guy can't come and
follow up and hurt him more and put him
out but at that moment I'm gonna let the
fight go because I see that his brain is
still working he can still function and
he's in a position where he can defend
himself
then you'll get to the next type of
knockdown the second type is going to be
where he gets hit and he's going
backwards but the difference is he
doesn't put his hands out and sometimes
guys are still they're not completely
out but they're going down and their
hands are starting to try to go that
direction but they're still either down
by their sides out in front of them
sometimes up that's one that's a step up
by far and that's you become more acute
to looking at the fighter and getting
information as quick as you can as far
as am I going to let that continue on or
am I going to take them out then you'll
get ones where guys fall to the sides
we as human beings don't fall going
sideways all right if I if I stand you
here sideways and I push you your foot's
going to automatically step out and
catch you but when your brain is
disconnected
your foot doesn't go out and so when you
get pushed you just start doing the
Leaning Tower and you end up going down
and so that's the next evolution of the
knockdown where someone's going down
going sideways it's telling you they're
having a problem their brain has been at
least disconnected where the neurons
aren't firing the right way the next
type you get is they go forward we don't
fall forward if I see you know come up
behind you and I push you as hard as I
can you're going to start to almost run
to stop that momentum and slow yourself
down and keep yourself from falling down
cause we've got these big flippers in
front of us they're called our feet but
if someone goes forward and goes down
it's telling you they've been
disconnected and the last one you'll see
is you'll get the ones where sometimes
guys just they get shut down like a
computer and you know Crow cop when he
got kicked by Gonzaga long ago and they
do this it's almost like they're a
building in in Vegas a hotel that's
being brought down and they implode upon
themselves
their brain's been completely shut off
it's telling you well those are things
that as a referee you're looking at and
you know so they help you as far as that
time you don't have a lot of time so you
utilize those things to give you an idea
of how hurt is that person but there's
times when we'll get guys that Benson
Henderson was the first you know was one
that a lot of people talked about
John couch is Benson's coach John couch
is an outstanding coach he just does a
great job with his guys but Benson
fought you know Rafael dos anjos and I
did the fight and he gets hit with a
shot and he gets hurt but he as he's
going down you can see his hand going
down and I'm coming in to look at him
but I know he's okay I'm going to let
him go and as he comes up he gets hit
with a shot and I watch him he just
implodes he goes out and I'm telling
myself I'm stopping the fight because he
cannot defend himself when he's out and
as he hits the ground he kind of comes
out but I'm already pulling dos Angels
out and John couch you know his coach is
going John John you you got to give him
a chance to recover and I said John he
went out
he goes no you gotta give me John it's
over and you know John and I have known
each other for years and we kind of had
this thing and finally you know I told
him I said you know shut the [__] up
and he looked at me and I said I don't
want to hear a goddamn thing and later
on you know he comes up to me and says
hey I'm sorry I said no I'm sorry I go
but he went out John I said how many
shots do you want me to take when he's
unconscious how many shots do you want
me to have him take and he goes no I
want you to protect him you did the
right thing but these are those things
we can never predict the future
we can always use hindsight to look back
and go ah you know that would have been
better if we did it this way but your
job is to protect the fighter when they
can't protect themselves and that is a
decision that is not an easy decision
because you want to let the fighter go
as far as they can go in the competition
I always say I want the guy you know I'm
going to let him swim into really deep
Waters but I am not going to let you
[__] drown okay that's not my job my
job is to keep you from drowning and if
you're starting to drown like Hector
Lombard was yesterday
fight's over you know it showed you look
at what happened he got a minutes rest
and then he comes back out and right
away what happened
he's done because he has pushed himself
past a point where his cardiovascular is
out and he's accepted so much damage at
that point he just doesn't function as
the fighter that he really is because
he's been altered by what Neil magni did
I've seen it a lot where a guy gets
clucked
and the flow wakes him up absolutely I
see it a lot and the more the more the
sport has progressed since having a fan
maybe eight years I see that you guys
catch it right away even the guy goes
what you were out and also I go whoa
what happened it was nice he's a replay
and sure enough just a tap you see the
eyes you see the hands
and then once they hit yeah now they're
back or whatever but they're not really
back they're just back in like uh you
know I got hit in that with a few pipes
I know exactly what it is I
it's that feeling get that buzz how
quickly does time move for you during
the fight I would imagine it goes really
slow you know what it does and that's
you know when people are asking me all
the time it's like they'll sit there and
go wow you did that really fast and then
I'll feel like you know Jose Aldo fights
you know Conor McGregor 13 seconds it's
not a lot a lot of time that was in that
fight but you know I can tell you every
second of what occurred where I was what
I saw
and you know when they first came out
you know Connor does a little kick and
then he throws a left hand and it
touches him stuff and you can see Jose
starts to bounce a little bit and he
comes forward and he goes to throw the
hook and Connor does a beautiful job of
stepping out boom he lands the left hand
while he still got hit and you know as
Jose is going down he's out he's out
he's out when he hits the ground he
actually wakes up and Conor comes down
in one hammer fist he goes out again
and I'm rushing in and as I'm rushing in
it feels like forever it feels like I
can't get there I'm running in mud I'm
trying to get as fast as I can get over
there because I'm seeing it and I want
to get there and it always feels like as
soon as you get done with it I should
have done that I should have been there
faster and you look at it afterwards you
go yeah that was actually not you know
that was I got there faster than I
thought because you do you do kind of
run in slow motion When does the when
does it start is it when like when you
get in the cave like when do you start
going in slow-mo no you don't the slow
motion is only when you have that you're
trying to get somewhere to stop
something you know during the during the
regular fight you know everything is the
same you know speeding them seeing
things exactly like everyone does I look
at things differently than the fans
looking at I'm looking at where shots
are landing I'm looking where things are
are at because that's part of my job but
I as the fights going on I you know
people ask me all the time you get
nervous and stuff like that no I don't
get nervous at all you know I get
excited for certain fights because I
want to see them I think it's gonna be a
great fight but you know I have a job to
do it I'm busy doing my job and
everything's normal it's always the time
when you're wanting to get somewhere
that it seems like that time is like it
slows down
do you ever get caught like enjoying a
fight or or like of course let's say
someone gets knocked out and you're like
oh [__] and then and then and then you
don't realize you're like oh no I have
to go get this guy that hasn't happened
as far as I've I've gone to a different
place no you know but I enjoy you know
while they're fighting at times you know
there's times inside I'm going oh
[__] that was awesome right or something
like that I'm not saying anything
everyone thinks I'm still mad because
everyone thinks I'm angry all the time
but I mean I'm I'm enjoying the hell out
of it because you you're close to what
some of these guys are doing
it's incredible sometimes and what's
incredible is some of what they take and
the Damage they take and they keep on
coming back you look at you know a
Robbie Lawler against a Rory McDonald
you know in that fight you look at what
went on in that and I could tell you you
know from the first round
you know it was fairly even and stuff
until Robbie landed a left hand that it
broke Rory's nose you could see it and
then Rory started having a lot of
problems that most people don't they
don't see they don't understand they
don't even realize it's happening
you know he's starting to get more
damage as the as round Goes On by the
end of it he's got a cut inside of his
mouth and he's got a broken nose and
then by the end of the second round he's
got another cut inside and then he's got
a cut underneath his eye well the cuts
around his eyes and stuff are not that
big a deal if as long as he's able to
see he's got to cut on the nose of his
bridge but the cut inside of his mouth
one of them is bad and it's bad that
he's having a lot of blood in his mouth
the blood in his mouth is not that big a
deal the nose that's broken is he's
bleeding down his throat that you know
as far as it going into his stomach
that's not a big deal you know if he
ends up taking so much he'll end up
throwing the blood out
but because his nose was broken you know
a fighter breathes through his nose and
he's he can't breathe through it so he's
got his mouth open and he's sucking in
these big gulps of air as the fight's
going on because he's becoming more
exhausted with what's going on and his
effort is still out there at a high
level but when he's sucking in the air
he's sucking in the blood is starting to
actually get little droplets that are
you know they're aspirating the droplets
of blood and going into his lungs
instead of dropping down into his
stomach and he's breathing that blood
and that blood is now starting to stick
inside of his lungs and it's starting to
make him slow down and so as the referee
I'm looking at it going when is Rory
going to fall off the cliff because he's
working at this High rate and I can see
what's occurring and I can see that he's
aspirating blood so I'm having doctors
come in between rounds to look at him to
say hey can he continue to go and you
know they keep on saying he's okay and
it comes to a point where you know he
gets hit with the one hand and the one
hand you know his nose was already
broken it hurt him but it was the
accumulation of everything and the
exhaustion because he is not having his
lungs work the way that they normally
work he's got this blood that is now
inside of him sticking and so that
oxygen transferred to his muscles has
been you know depleted by we'll say 50
percent
he's he's running on these fumes and
he's continuing to push and go hard to
the point where he just you know like
anything like any mechanical you know
car or plane it just gets to a point
where the pressure builds too much and
it busts but those are the things that
as a referee I'm looking at while the
fans going this is a great fight
that was a great fight oh it was a great
fight I know from uh you know getting
hit in the nose a lot of things happen
and yeah people at home don't know these
things that's what really gets me the
MMA Community is so intelligent in so
many ways and so many other ways they're
so lost you know they're so [__] lost
yeah you know and it's that's why I
started going to jiu jitsu
that is the reason why and now I
understand a lot more what's going on
well not a lot more
but I understand breathing and he's on
his back and this guy's on top of you
the whole for four rounds the guy's on
top of you there's a lot of pressure on
pounds I'm just throwing punches I can't
even imagine I can't have somebody in my
clothes guard for four minutes I can't
imagine a guy throwing bombs on you
you're trying to get an underhook or
whatever the hell it is but that that's
amazing about Rory that you wouldn't
know that at home I just thought his
nose is broken and he's having a hard
time breathing because once what happens
when your nose gets broken if you blow
it you're [__] now that's if you if
you break if you if you break an orbital
one of your orbitals in your eyes which
is these really small bones that on top
and bottom that it you know it basically
holds your eyeball in place they're a
very thin bone and they can crack but if
they crack and you blow your nose or the
pressure of you doing it is going to
send
air from your sinuses into that cavity
because now there's a bone that's been
split so that in your eye kind of goes
and blows up like a balloon real fast
like Matt material like well Matt
mitrion's was blood there's a difference
his was done by a break in the orbital
and then there was blood that filled
into it also
that's why it got big and kind of
purplish looking right away what does a
bone sound like when it's being like Oh
smashed into a thousand pieces like that
was the thing when I went to I've only
been to one UFC and I like just hearing
the kicks and all that stuff was crazy
but being three feet away from a bone
just you know I was mashing to a million
pieces well they don't smash but they do
snap and it's kind of like a stick so
and you hear it you definitely hear it
when it goes dog when I was about 17 I
was playing basketball one night and a
cop pulled up
there's a buddy of mine he was got to
get in the car friends getting into a
fight and he's by himself over there
let's go
and we went over there and as we pulled
up our friend there was like eight guys
there and our friend had a t-shirt off
he had his uh jeans on he had work boots
on
as we were getting out of the car the
game's like ready ready
the guy threw one punch and our friend
came up and caught him in the face
would have worked with the steel tip and
it was like something out of a movie he
caught him right here at the guy I you
know all I I didn't see as much as the
foot hitting because there was a circle
of people already I just heard
like the Lee you should have just yeah
and you just he just went backwards and
his nose was open like it was busted
here and blood was coming out already
but as the minutes were going up all
this was starting to swell it was
horrible I had to get in the car and get
the [__] out of there before the cops
got that his name was compa compa and he
was just a karate guy he was a bartender
and he went to this bar and he was
having problems and it was like we want
to fight you okay I'll fight you hold on
at least let me wait for my friends to
get here so I feel comfortable and they
let him and he just first fight bam done
and I saw that and I was like you know
what I ain't going back to karate can
you explain that again that's something
that I don't think most people deal with
he kicked him in the face he was at a
bar he was at a bar
and we're playing basketball my friend
pulls up Lefty Cortina he's a teacher
now in Washington High School and he
goes get in the car a friend whatever
the compass got into a fight he wants to
stay but it was in a fight it was like a
he agreed to fight the Mana bar yeah and
called you guys in yeah just so he had
to back up so but I'm a young kid this
guy's 24-25 he's a bartender in the city
somewhere I just know him because we
used to play basketball my friend
Lefty's backyard and he was always there
Lefty's father was a [__] doctor and
he had a huge backyard growing up so
we'd play hours of basketball back then
he was one of the guys that played so
the night that I happened to go back
there with him and he calls me over this
guy got kicked in the face with a work
boot
you have no ideally you have no idea and
he just lay there he just lay there
another night I seen a friend of mine
Tommy Russo clocked this [__]
outside of Tom and Corky's and the guy
went down and his eyes started blinking
I ran like 15 blocks before I stopped I
was never so scared because you know I
grew up on if you're there you're an
accessory like that type of [__] I
wasn't there there I was standing
outside hanging out with these guys and
all of a sudden these guys got into a
fist fight it's scary I I can't I don't
I don't even want to be a part I got
beat up a couple times and that's the
best one man I think we're like at least
talking about you get these you know
some of these guys you know gypsies or
Travelers or you know these these guys
live by the bare knuckle boxing as their
way of settling disputes and they set it
up you know they got this guy that's got
to dispute with him and the only thing
they set it up to the point boom you
know and they fight it out sometimes you
know for them you know they they still
don't like each other but it's been
settled you know and you get a lot of
these guys you know the bare knuckle
boxing champion right now because there
actually is there's a guy named Bobby
Gunn Bobby Gunn was a cruiserweight in
boxing he was world champion at one
point and then Bobby has been fighting
you know the bare knuckle boxing for a
long time and he's smart about it man
you watch some of these guys fighting
these bare knuckle uh things it's not
like people think
you know it's intelligent fighting it's
all set up but they're all staged up
together because someone had a dispute
over here and this guy didn't like it
over here so we're gonna settle it and
it's when you were a kid in the second
grade this guy stole your [__] a race
oh yeah what did you do you met him
outside in front of the school with
three o'clock I mean everybody was happy
that's it that's when I was growing up
there was a fight once a month at three
o'clock you could count it like that
like the after-school movie it counted
it was always a great little fist fight
something
now you know whatever what are you gonna
do hey dude you know what if you grew up
like with my dad man you know what it
was okay to fight the big thing was you
weren't supposed to start it but if
someone wanted to fight you better
stand up to him because if I find out
that you didn't you're going to be taken
down there and you're gonna
until you beat his ass every day you're
gonna be going back
that's just the way that's the way I was
raised and I went down completely lost
on when it comes to MMA you know
people again the MMA Community is very
intelligent
some of them right and at the other end
it's a complete whatever and I'm part of
that complete whatever but I don't make
points about it it's the point system
it I've never
etched to find out because it's not my
occupation and I don't want to sit there
with people and argue with what I saw
and what they saw and after a fight in
Vegas we're going to eat and every fight
there's a fight on the car this is a
decision and they sit there for two
hours what do you think I don't know
what the [__] to think I saw him
punching him in the face 18 times but
takedowns are big and at the end of the
round and controlling somebody on the
gate who's the aggressor there's so many
little things that I don't really know
like even if you punch me in the head
eight times but I I chase you down all
[__] night I went you know no no no
you lose you got punched in the head
eight times but if I was aggressing you
like chasing you and maybe who knows so
Lee had what what what the [__] I said
before I was just wondering if there was
a reason why there couldn't be some sort
of scoreboard I know they do like
significant strikes and they do all that
but in my head what I was imagining was
if you've ever watched like World Poker
Tour they have like their percentage
chance of winning they show you the
guy's hands you're saying well they show
you their hands and uh and they show you
the percentages of their chance to win
I just for the average fan
it would
probably it would get rid of a lot of
those arguments but actually maybe the
UFC likes that it keeps them talking
about the fights maybe that's maybe
that's why they do it you know in in
boxing they tried they put up uh what
they called publicized scoring and at
the end of the round they would project
the score of the judges up onto a screen
so you would know who was winning in
that fight and
it's like anything a certain type of
scoring system is going to work in one
fight where it doesn't work as well in
another fight and so what you they ended
up having is they had fights where it
actually made the peoples that you know
seeing it they realize I'm behind and
they're going after the person realigns
I need to win this round or both
Fighters know I need to win this last
round and it makes for an exciting fight
yeah it sounds like it but
what they found out also was that many
times we had this person that was
winning and he won the first six rounds
of a 10-round fight and then he just
decided to take it off and cruise
because he knows that he's he's up the
only thing he can't doesn't want to have
happen is get knocked down and so
the fighter ended up actually making it
a boring fight because he's not fighting
now he's just being a defensive fighter
and so they looked at and said it helps
in some and it hurts in others and so
they kind of got away from it I was
going to take it be only for the TV but
then they'd have people attacking us
yeah exactly if you're gonna you're
gonna put it out there you're gonna
publicize it they're gonna have a way of
knowing and so yeah both ways the
fighter will go but this happened in the
UFC maybe a year ago I think it was
maybe the the Greg Jackson camp
in between rounds you got a microphone
over there the UFC
and he sent this fighter in to tell him
that he was ahead in points and he
really wasn't and Dana
said something after a fight sending
your fighter and letting them know you
were ahead of point so
I don't know how it went down I don't
know if you remember how it went down or
somebody said something in between
around to one of their Fighters
and letting them know they were down I
don't know I just
I get [__] confused well you mean you
get a lot you know that
Craig Jackson and Mike winklejohn you
know they have a system you know people
it's it's funny because they're they're
one of the best I've ever seen they
influence judges and because if you have
Greg and micro together Greg's the
grappling guy for the most part Mike is
the Striking guy for the most part and
so if they have a fight where the fight
ends up on the ground you're gonna hear
Greg giving instruction he's going to be
telling his fighter what to do and
you're going to hear Winkle John become
the cheerleader and he's going to start
you're doing beautiful that's it
beautiful beautiful elbow from
underneath that way you know and he
starts cheerleading if it's opposite and
it's a stand-up fight you're going to
hear Winkle John giving the instruction
and you're going to hear Greg Jackson
beautiful that a beautiful left hand
that's the way that's what we're looking
for and it gives all this stuff because
they've got it down to where they know
they have codes that they say and
they're telling the fighter you know
what they need but they're also kind of
trying to influence the judge who's
sitting somewhere by him because
there'll be one and I can tell you you
know I've gone I normally don't look at
you know scorecards but I'll watch a
fight and it'll have you know one of
Greg's fighters in it and I'll watch the
round and I know his fighter boss
there's no doubt about it and I'll go up
to the corner that the judge is sitting
near his corner and I'll pick up the
scorecard and God damn if he didn't give
it to freaking he gets influenced and
you've got to learn how to keep that
from happening that's part of being a
professional and stuff but when you're
looking at the scoring the scoring is
not like people think and that's the
biggest problem is you know the UFC and
this is not not against the UFC but they
put information out on the screen Joe
Rogan says things at times you go no
that's not right you're putting out bad
information and the information they're
putting out is they sit you know they
basically put up on the screen before
the whole show starts is you know this
is the judge you know judges are scoring
the fights on you know effective
striking effective grappling ring or
octagon control and effective
aggressiveness okay well they're making
someone look at and say well those are
all the elements and so you score them
all evenly no you don't okay there's
only two elements of a fight all right
if I sit here and you know if Joey and I
are gonna fight and Joey decides to move
forward okay and come after me and look
mean and
he doesn't hit me once he doesn't grab a
hold of me and clinch and take me to the
ground he does nothing as far as
striking or grappling what do we have
we've got ugly guys dancing
okay doing nothing that's not a fight
okay let's talk about where it's the
cage control we'll we'll say I stand in
the center of the cage and I make and
Joey's he's bouncing around the outside
and you know I'll take steps towards him
and he kind of backs out and then you
know I'll let him come towards me and
I'm still in the center and boom I'll
make a faint and he backs out again
it's had dancing it's not fighting
there's only two elements that make up
the fighting as far as that scoring and
that is effective striking and effective
grappling and it's your ability to
understand what is effective striking
effective striking is not being the one
and you get these the usual put out you
know the significant strike stats
whoever pushes that button is a [__]
[__] okay has no idea of what the
judges are looking for as a fight and
doesn't understand what's important in
the fight because it's not how many
times someone takes their hand hits
another person in the head body or
anything like that it's how much force
did he do it with because if I ask you
right now I'm gonna sit here and say I'm
gonna hit you with four Jabs quick Jabs
okay or I'm gonna hit you with one giant
right hand that hits you upside the head
which ones do you want you want the four
you want the one four Jabs Bingo because
you're an intelligent human being
because it's not going to damage you as
much so you're not going to take the big
right hand that's going to damage you
more than the four but if we look at a
significant strikes we have four to one
right which one is the one that's more
important the big powerful right hand is
the one that's more important and so
that's what the judge is looking for we
had to fight with Carlos Condit against
Robbie Lawler and it really came down to
one round
the judges were exactly the same on
every round except for the third round
two judges went with Robbie and one
judge went with Carlos Carlos being out
of Jackson Winkle John okay and you can
sit there and you can watch that fight
I can break it down perfectly for you
because significant strike wise the UFC
counters basically had Carlos you know
throwing three times as many punches
as Robbie Lawler they're right he threw
80 punches in that round while Robbie
through 26. all right but if you look at
the true significant strikes the ones
that landed the ones that actually had
an effect in the fight out of the 80
that Carlos threw and I was the one
referring it so I'm telling you as I was
in there the whole time going he's
missing he's missing he's missing
out of the 80 that he threw he actually
landed nine that I would give is
significant now if you want to count his
front lead leg kick to the lower leg of
Robbie which doesn't do anything you can
Bounce It Up to 14. okay that's what he
landed as we'll say significant but not
any of them were that heavy
we look at Robbie Lawler 26 is all he
threw but he had 12 that were
significant that landed with heavy power
one being the best one which was an
elbow that he hit Carlos with it that
made Carlos react and go back and you
look at everything and the judges the
two got it right Carlos won the round
it's not who throws the most it doesn't
matter how much you throw it matters how
much you damage how much are you
connecting and how much damage and how
much deterioration are you doing against
that fighter that's what they're looking
for it's not about it's not a game a tag
if it's a game of tag then it's how many
times you tag them but in MMA when it
comes to the Striking it's effective
shots that have power the judge is
looking for damage he's looking for big
shots that do damage to that fighter
that's what they're looking for first
then they're looking for quantity
the Nick Diaz land a bunch of shots but
you know I'll tell you you know being
someone's been there with me he he lands
a lot of shots but then he'll Land once
that have power too but we'll give over
you know a couple if you know if we're
gonna say you know two powerful shots he
landed the whole thing but this guy
landed you know 43 shots well the 43 are
going to win quantity is going to beat
the quality in that because it's so much
this is what the judge is weighing out
then you get into the grappling and you
have all these people thinking that a
takedown is this giant element in the
fight it's not it's what you do with the
takedown that's the element if you take
somebody down there's a way to get
points on the judge's score how many
points do you get for a tape now there's
not a specific point thing but it's what
type of takedown do you hit them with if
you get a takedown or you know what you
work and all of a sudden you you know I
hook you know hook the leg inside trip
and then we both go down
there's nothing really that that
takedown did other than change the level
of the field instead of us being now
both vertical or both horizontal so what
are you going to do with that takedown
now that we're on the ground that will
let the judge say okay I'm giving you
that was a takedown because now you're
doing good work on the ground you get
credit for that takedown but if you take
the fight down and you don't do anything
with it it was no different than if
we're in the stand up and I take this
great angle on you and I go to throw a
shot and it misses and nothing I don't
get credit for the angle I took I get
credit for what I was going to do with
the angle same thing with the takedown
now we can have a takedown where you
know I get a hold of you and I get
behind you and all of a sudden I'm
suplexing you over that's a takedown
that has what we call amplitude it has
elevation and impact if we get a
takedown that has elevation of the
fighter and boom he comes down and
there's big impact the judge is going to
give a good score as far as they're
going to put that into you just did
something that affected the fighter in
the fight I'm going to put that towards
you winning the round doesn't mean you
know if you don't do anything else
you're going to win it just because of
it but that is a takedown that's going
to score for you with the judges in
their minds that was significant if you
have that type of takedown we have it
but we can have takedowns where I get
somebody really high and then there's a
struggle and also we end up on the
ground but there was no impact
so what are you going to do with it
that's what the judge is looking for so
when the judge is now looking you take
the person down you stay in their guard
and you put your head in the middle of
the chest and you go body body head and
you do that for a minute and a half and
this guy on the bottom is hitting with
elbows and stuff you're not doing
anything to win yourself the fight the
judge is not going to be giving you
credit for that takedown because
you're not doing anything that's
impacting the fight now you take the
fight down and you hit him with heavy
shots on the ground
you make that person have problems
they're going to say that that was a
good takedown that led to more things
they're going to give you credit for it
Frank yankov Swanson
every time Frank Cub Swanson threw a
fight Frankie got him with that little
thing he has and he takes you down I'll
enjoyed Saint Peter what did he do with
the takedown
Cub was in trouble right Frankie was on
top of him right he's getting credible
takedown okay this is an education for
me I knew nothing of this I thought all
takedown to like Jiu-Jitsu four points
instead of not three that's how confused
I was you know and that's what we get
we'll get a lot of guys that get I come
from Jiu Jitsu and they're sitting there
too but he got Mound he did nothing with
it the judge isn't going to give you any
credit for mine it's not Four Points all
right you get side control you don't get
three points it's what do you do with
the side control what do you do with
them out in in fighting especially
because of strikes with MMA there's a
lot we can do with that mouth well just
do it go after him we're looking for the
fighter to try to do things to end the
fight your job is to go in there and
from the moment the fight starts your
job is to do things that are going to
cause you to be able to end the fight
down the road be it 10 seconds down the
road be at 20 be it two minutes be it 10
minutes be at 15 minutes you're always
working to end the fight that's what we
want out of the fighter why doesn't the
UFC just have refs do the judging
because they have a few rafts there like
one isn't it just not round robin
because the biggest complaint I've heard
about the judges is that they aren't
aware of the rules of the sport like
there might be blocking judges so they
might not know grappling you know and
that's not true look at it that's not
true no yeah I hate to say it it's you
get you get these it's like you know
painting you know the broad Strokes are
there people what what happened with MMA
is when MMA started to get really going
with a lot of Regulation a lot of these
states were not prepared to have people
judging and so they had people that were
martial artists or boxing people they
said I can do that and because they were
people that the athletic commission okay
and they put them in there and those
people had no idea how to truthfully do
this the correct way and so that caused
problems and it's taken a long time but
if you look at the people that are out
there judging fights you know now you
know the Derrick Cleary's the salamatos
the Chrisleys
you know all these people that are you
know the ones that a lot of people are
seeing a lot they're very good at what
they do and they're very serious about
what they do and they they're going back
and they're trust me if if I show you my
phone after a big fight if there's a
decision those guys are all texting me
John did you watch a fight yeah because
they want to know it did I see something
wrong did I do something wrong and it is
the one thing that you know off of
judging is judging no matter what we try
to objectify it as much as we can but
it's always going to be subjective and
the one thing that most people don't get
is we get this where we have these
judges we put them at these three
different positions in that you know
cage the UFC doesn't give them good
seats they give one a good seat two of
them have the cage door right by them so
they got posts that are blocking their
view a lot of the time they have a
referee that's moving around inside so
there's many times that these two judges
are going to see something occur why
this guy doesn't see it at all because
he has something in his way and that's
you know what they're doing in that
position it's it's not the best seats
that they can give them the worst thing
that we do is we put judges here down on
the floor and we have this octagon
that's up here and so they're looking up
the whole time
if you took them and put them above
that octagon they're going to see more
they're going to be able to see a lot
more that goes on and they won't miss as
much but we don't put them up there
because then they're blocking people's
views and I can understand that too but
you know we don't do our judges any
favors in how we you know where we put
them and what we expect of them there's
a lot that's expected it is not an easy
job and there's always going to be when
you're watching a fight most times you
have people that are they're rooting for
one person over the other they want if
it's you know Frankie Edwards gonna
fight you know Conor McGregor there's
we'll say 50 that want Conor McGregor
and 50 want Frankie Edgar so the the 50
that want Connor whatever Connor does
they give it more credit than it
deserves and whatever Frankie does is
not quite as good as it really was and
so by the end they look at it oh it's
easy Conor won that when the judge is
not they don't give a [__] who wins all
they want to know is for five minutes
I'm going to give concentration I'm
going to watch everything that I can and
I'm going to look and I'm gonna I'm
gonna read what the fighter is telling
me because Fighters speak
they're not talking verbally but through
body motions they're telling the judges
what hurts sometimes they do things that
it really didn't hurt them but they have
this habit of doing something that's
telling the judge it it hurts by how
much they'll give and give ground and
you know flop back into the cage fence
or something like that and you tell them
afterwards dude you're doing stuff
that's telling the judges that hurt you
that had impact you got to stop doing
that but the judge is reading that
fighter because the fighter talks you
watch Johnny case when he was fighting
yesterday and you see him you know he's
doing really good and all of a sudden
this kid throws a front kick to his his
body and he gets hit and you see him
just do this and he sets down on it that
body motion is telling the judge that
hurt
it's going to get credit in my score and
those are the things that they're
looking for out of the fighter
do you get any input at all as a referee
or no input into who wins yeah like no
no well I get input when it's oh that
guy does not know
like what percentage of these
controversial decisions could be fixed
by those issues that you said the
problem is when you sit there and you
say controversial decision most of the
time it's not controversial it's a close
fight and again you have
half wanting one fighter and half
wanting the other fighter and so all
this half says those judges were
absolutely right they're smart it's a
great job and this half saying those
judges sucked it's not it's there are
close fights so the media is just
feeding into that absolutely
controversial absolutely the media puts
it out there's a country you know right
away you had Benson Henderson fought Gil
Melendez up here in San Jose yeah it's
probably about three years ago Benson
Henderson was a champion Gil Melendez
was coming out of Strike Force he was
the champion there and they matched him
up and it was a close fight I was a
referee for it man and I'm telling you
what at the end of it I was like thank
God I didn't have to judge that okay
because I knew it was that close and all
the scores
were the same except for one round two
judges went one way one judge went the
other and Benson Henderson wins a split
decision over Gil Melendez one round's
the difference same as Robbie Lawler
fighting Carlos Condit one round one
judge goes one way two goes the other
that's the difference and everyone goes
it's controversial it's not
controversial it's a close fight and the
judges are telling you it's a close
fight by what they're seeing and that's
just the way it is when you've only got
three or five rounds you know sometimes
they don't work themselves out you know
to the end
no I hate when people come you know
after a fight what'd you think Joey how
do you score it I don't I don't I don't
even know where to start and that's the
best part dude I don't know how to score
a fight I just I just know how to enjoy
it now
a fight's coming to Glendale
UFC's coming to Glendale and I raised my
hand and I want to be a [__] joke
coming to Glendale what's the process
you want to be a judge I'm just
hypodermic whatever the [__] this is
hypodermically or hypothetic
hypothetically I want to be a judge uh
I'm a blob I'm a black belt and
traditional karate I've won a couple
competitions I have my own school I had
a baby okay let's pretend what is my
process the true process now here in the
state of California since Glendale is
California if you want to be we'll say a
judge first off that's awesome we love
the fact that you want to be a judge so
now we're going to tell you okay so what
we need you to do is go to the gym and
start learning everything that these
guys are doing okay everything that
there is you I need you to understand
the ground I need you to understand
every submission there is I need you to
understand what that submission is what
it's affecting and how it needs to be
defended I need you to understand the
stand-up game I need you to understand
what those kicks are exactly where
they're targeted at why they're targeted
there what's effective what's not I want
you to tell me exactly when we talk
about stand up I need you to be able to
tell me who's winning the stand up and
why when we have these certain elements
occur
so I need you to start going to the gym
and that's going to take you honestly
yeah you need to be there for several
years before you're going to have the
night begins I've been a martial artist
since I was saying I walked into okay
all right so we'll say that you're that
martial artist that's become a black
belt traditional Taekwondo and a purple
belt in your YouTube okay okay I'm 35 I
competed a couple times I got a couple
gold medals or whatever you know locally
you couldn't come up with silver hat
that ugly guy I just wanna I wanna know
how the the neighborhood
traditional martial arts all right so
we'll say that you're a guy that's been
involved in fighting like that right so
you're that guy that's been involved so
you don't have to start going to the gym
so now what you're gonna have to do is
you're gonna have to pick and you're
gonna have to go to a certified course
all right here in California there's
only two that you can choose from
all right that's going to be John
McCarthy's or herb Deans not your not
your gig the judge yeah the guy who
scores judging okay okay here you go so
you got two courses that you can go take
you can go take herb Dean's uh uh MMA
Camp I think is what he calls it or you
can go to John McCarthy's command course
okay so if you're gonna do that for
judging it's gonna be a two-day course
in mind it's a one day for herbs so in
the two days I'm gonna go through
everything that is the criteria for you
for judging MMA we're going to talk
about those things we're going to talk
about what the criteria is for it what
you need to be looking at breaking
things down into quality over quantity
all these things demonstrations I am
going to have you
sit down and you're gonna we're gonna go
through submissions and we're gonna go
through okay look at this is what an
eviscerator is this is what Avon
fluchoke is this is what
an anaconda here's a Darth here's your
arm bar and we're gonna go through all
these things we're gonna go through
takedowns we're going to go through
here's your double leg here's your
single leg here's your uchimada here is
your siennagi here's what how to gosh is
and we're going to go through all those
things and then we're going to start
watching fights and we're going to put
fights on that are fights that are going
to demonstrate certain things that I
want to point out to you we're going to
have you judge the fights we're going to
have you talk about why you judge that
round the way you did we're going to
talk about you know what you needed to
look at and then you're going to get
tested on this and you're in that test
you're going to end up having to
uh in mind you're going to end up having
you're gonna have to take a techniques
test so you'll get 120 different things
that are going to be put out there this
could be you know what a suplex it could
be you know a
a arm bar it can be an Americana it
could be positioned basically you know
side control uh x-guard you know mission
control all these different elements of
fights that you see the element
I need you to be able to tell me that's
exactly what it is because you need to
understand what you're looking at so if
you can pass that with a 90 or above
then you move on and then you go to
you're going to have to go and now
you're going to take a written test the
written test is going to be things that
you need to know about MMA for you know
the association of boxing commissions
who governs all the regulatory bodies
throughout North America that's the test
that you know we they want you to have
and so you have a written test then
you're going to take a test on a fight
and you're going to watch a fight and
you're going to watch that fight and
you're going to judge the fight and as
you're judging the fight after the round
you're going to write down your score
and you're going to tell me exactly why
you picked the fighter that you did in
that round what elements were that
changed you from saying I'm going to go
with this fighter
I'll go to this one and this is why this
is what he did better this is where he
was you know the more effective fighter
and you'll do that for a five round
fight and if you don't get if you don't
get that score right you you're going to
fail that and so you've got to fail all
you got to pass all these things at 90
percent
you pass that you pass the course and
from that point you can now go to
amateur MMA we in the state of
California we have the camo which is
California amateur mixed martial arts
organization they do all the amateur
fights here in California and your name
will go to their database and you can
sign up to be an official with camo and
eventually what they're going to do is
they're going to bring you in as an
inspector someone that actually watches
the fighters in the back watches the
taping of hands learns how hands are
legally taped all the different things
that happen in the back you're the one
that's going to walk out with the
fighter you know when they are going to
the ring you'll be in their Corner
you're the one controlling their Corner
things they're going to start you out
there and eventually they'll say hey
we've got this show and we're going to
have you Shadow judge it and you'll
start Shadow judging other judges so
you're going to sit next to the judge
that's actually the judge of it and
you're going to give your score while
they're giving their score and you're
going to turn your score in and once
your scores are in line where you know
what you're judging things right they're
going to give you that opportunity and
start to judge and from that you get to
judge you have to judge for at least two
years
here as an amateur judge before you can
even think about trying to get a license
with the state of California as a
professional and once you get the if the
state of California decides they're
thinking about giving you that license
you're going to start doing that shadow
judging thing again and going to shows
on your own time sitting next to the
judges and giving a shadow judge score
until they see you know what this guy
does we're going to give him a chance
and then you're going to start off in
the slow shows and your little small
shows that you're going to be going to
and you're going to be doing those for
several years and eventually if you've
proven yourself and you've gotten to the
point where you've proven that you
understand how to judge a fight and you
are in the upper scale of the people
that they have
when that UFC comes to town maybe after
about six to eight years you might be
put onto that UFC UFC Bellator yeah yeah
one of those things you know that's a
long process it's a lot more than people
think no I thought it was like a 90 day
yeah yeah and that's why there was so
many [__] bad scores sometimes that's
why I thought there was something you
know from what you're telling me
and what I'm thinking about the only
thing I can think about for bad scoring
is which this is how naive I am about
that stuff like
I can't believe that you would judge a
fight going 50 percent
for Nate Diaz or 50 for Conor McGregor
in your mind
I figured it'd be a way you to take no
no no I'm saying the fans 50 want Nate
to win and 50 want Conor to win so those
50 no matter what they do they kind of
look at it and they're always they're
always siding with their fighter you
know the judge doesn't give a [__] who
wins the judge is giving credit for what
is being done in the fight they don't
care if Conor McGregor wins they don't
care if Nate Diaz wins they care that
the right person wins and trust me it's
a huge difference we did a thing here in
California
where we actually did I did a small
course
and did a little teaching thing for the
media and we're talking about guys from
you know MMA fighting ESPN you know guys
that are you know the bigger you know
MMA Outlets as far as you know the media
they came and you know they watched
some stuff we talked about it and then
we took him out of Bellator and we put
them next to the judges and had them
judge the fights and afterwards they all
said I'm never going on the media
anymore and saying oh this is
controversial because they got that feel
they understood what it was like and the
pressure that's involved and they
realized afterwards that hey there's
times that you know what I didn't get to
see that because the referee was in the
way I didn't see when that supposedly
happened and it happens that's just part
of it
as the you know there's all these
different things people are trying to do
oh let's put them in a room or something
like that sound is a big element it's
the same thing as what you were talking
about with that boot when it hit that
man that's all I remember that's all I
ever remember what did that sound tell
you that his face was gone that it
absolutely
gone and I didn't see it I was coming
this way yeah I heard it maybe 15 yards
and it was the weird like everything he
had caved in something that came that
sound told you
oh man that had impact sounds important
for a judge a judge uses their ears to
say that was effective that wasn't and
so you know all of this is not there's
nothing perfect the problem is everyone
looks at the UFC and goes those are UFC
judges there's no freaking UFC judges
what the UFC does is they're smart
enough there's no UFC the only UFC
referees there is any you know if you
want to say it was John McCarthy and
Mario yamasaki okay long ago I was
working for the UFC before there was you
know all the regulation I was a guy that
would you know go to the shows and stuff
and I was under contract with them and
then they brought in Mario after a while
because they needed another referee and
we were working for the UFC but
once you know this whole thing got you
know bigger and stuff in state
regulations
I couldn't do that anymore and that's
why you know I worked for the state of
Nevada I worked for the State of
California I'm licensed in a lot of
different states because if you're the
state if you know Annie Foster is the
boss of California's athletic commission
he's the executive director he has five
bosses over the top of him that are the
Commissioners but he's the one that's
doing most of the legwork
and he's going to tell you straight out
you know why do I put you know John
McCarthy or Herb Dean as my referee why
do I want them because he takes that
they take the pressure off of me if John
McCarthy goes out there and makes a
mistake in the big UFC no one's going to
look at me as Andy Foster and say you
screwed up by making by putting him as a
referee but if you put somebody in that
is someone that a lot of people don't
know or has less experience and they
mess up you know you you look at you
know what people are talking about with
you know the magni Lombard fight Steve
Percival is the referee he's taken a lot
of heat
okay right now over that fight and he's
that heat is now being secondarily
placed onto the commission that's there
in Australia because they use him
if if you're Andy Foster and you use
Herb Dean or John McCarthy we screw up
everyone everyone attacks John McCarthy
and they attack her Dean but they don't
attack the state of California and Andy
Foster because who else did you expect
him me to put in there who's going to be
better
and so you know that's what the UFC
looks at at times with people they try
to get these athletic commissions hey we
will pay
the UFC is paying for my travel for herb
Dean's travel for Sal diamattos for
Derek clears wherever it is you know
when I when I travel somewhere the UFC's
paying for my my plane ticket they're
they're paying for my hotel room because
they're wanting to have these people
that they believe in that they they
believe understand this sport to the
point where the chance of the mistake is
going to be less and so they're willing
to do that but they still can't force
that on
these state regulations and these these
athletic commissions there so you can
have an athletic commissions will say
you know we'll say North Dakota is going
to the us is going to do a fight there
they're going to have people that have
been working there in the state now the
UFC is going to say Hey you know we have
this list of all these people you can
pick who you want but these are people
that sometimes come to our shows we will
pay for them to come we'll pay for all
the stuff you just have to you know pick
which ones you want but they can't force
that State athletic commission to pick
any of them and the State athletic
commission can sit there and say nope
we're going to go with all of our people
and that's what they'll do and then
hopefully nothing bad happens but if
something bad happens then it goes back
on that person and then the State
athletic commission is looked at as bad
so there's this weird balance of people
doing things you know trying to get you
know people that they like you know you
look at what happened in
Massachusetts with the mattreon fight
the person that was the referee there is
from Massachusetts he doesn't do a lot
of fights he hasn't do a lot of shows
there's not a ton of practical
experience over and over you know I'm
doing I do usually two shows a week you
know if you if you're doing six shows in
the year
there's there's a difference there as
far as just repetition and being able to
you know be more up on things and so
that's what happens with these places
though the UFC Bellator they can't force
these commissions to bring in these
referees or these judges that are the
guys that have proven themselves to be
the higher standard of the sport
I have learned more from this podcast
and now I get now I can say you know
because the only problem I see is I like
the idea of raising
that you're absolutely right well
couldn't they just watch from like above
in like a Skybox or something you know
what and this is the whole thing again
sound it is it's a sound sound
I was there with Johnny Hendrix knocked
out John Fitch yeah it sounded like a
[__] firecracker went off you know I
was there when what's his name kicked
and I had judge like those are the best
seats for me when Anderson kicked what's
his name in the face those are the first
ones that Joe didn't get his floor seats
we sat on the sides and that was a
better seat I saw everything I saw
little things that and then at home you
see a lot more yeah who's not yelling go
[__] yourself who's not falling down the
stairs let's never have uh you know big
breasts walking down the thing who's
sitting next to you look who it is so
you get distracted
you know there's something about being
at the fight you know Dana says it all
the time and he's being honest when he's
saying it fights are electric you know
the the energy in the crowd and I'm
gonna tell you right now if you want to
watch the fight the best that you can
watch it at home but if you want to
experience the fight the greatest way to
experience it is be a theory you know be
there because it's the crowd and the
energy and everything there you're not
going to see the fight as clearly when
you're there but you absolutely will get
the entire you know experience more by
being there the experience is beautiful
oh yeah Lee we went one couple that was
amazing it's a beautiful experience as
far as you know the music the sound the
the how loud it is who you know Uriah
Fame is sitting over here who's not
sitting over there you know this chick
from My Name is Earl remember we were
going for a long time yeah Jamie Presley
would always go and you know that's the
but after a while like getting the [__]
out of there is a nightmare like I had
it down to a science once the [__]
the last fight started the first round
went all the way I got up Jack be right
back will you go I'll be right back I'm
gonna go up to the top of the stairs
watch and take my time and watch and
then the fight went to the third round
you always went into the hole when they
got TVs and you sit there like a doctor
nobody bothers you as soon as somebody
gets knocked out I'm out of there I
don't wait in the hallway I don't hear
about who got robbed it's a [__] bum
decision [__] you uh let's take a
picture but the experiences are amazing
I
know that I get lost sometimes
watching stand up
Dave Chappelle's at the store
and I go back there and I'm in with him
for three minutes I'm [__] with him
Big John yeah I'm giggling and all of a
sudden something happens and I go away
for 10 seconds whatever happened to you
just 10 seconds it never happened to me
and then it comes right back and you're
like okay you know what I'm saying like
and it's not that you drift you're still
watching it but something goes away for
a little while I'm gonna just comes back
like not like that like when Elise said
holy [__] look at that knockout and also
you're on top of that oh my God I would
die
you know what you know as someone then
when you're working them you're intent
in your your whole thing is
what people don't realize is you have a
huge responsibility and it's a
responsibility that you know it's not
understood until you're put in that
position that
yeah I've had Fighters Wives come up to
me after their husband is lost and
they've come up and said thank you thank
you for protecting him and you look and
you go hey my pleasure you know and I
can't tell you how much I respect the
guys that I get to work with what I get
to do you know I'm honored by being able
to be in there and do what I do but I
take it serious and I take it to the
point of I do care about the fighters I
do care that they don't take what I call
unnecessary damage a fighter is going to
be damaged that is part of being a
professional fighter it's part of what
they sign up for you're gonna get hurt
you're gonna you know there's things
that are gonna be done inside that cage
sometimes you know nothing you know
you're Conor McGregor you win in 13
seconds you still got to cut over your
eye okay you're gonna get damaged that
is part of what you signed up for with
this sport but when it comes to being
damaged there comes a point where it
becomes unnecessary damage and and
that's what I can't take I can't have
people being damaged beyond that one
point and when they start to take
unnecessary damage that's when I'm there
to stop it and because as the referee
you know there's a club out there all
right and that club is of people that
don't want to be in it those are
officials that have been in charge of
fights where Fighters have come in
they've given everything they could and
they were not able to walk out of that
caging ring they died all right this is
serious sport this is a sport where
people can die and if you allow that to
happen now there's some things that can
happen there completely out of your
control but there's that point where you
know you should have stopped the fight
but you let it go because of all people
in the crowd when you you know wanted
you to or whatever your excuse is you
let it go that person dies
you're gonna live with that for the rest
of your life you will sit there and
Replay that moment of when you should
have stopped it for the rest of your
life that is something that will never
go away and there's a lot you know I can
start naming them off for you there's a
ton of referees that have been
part of fights where a person has died
and they've all taken their lives
they've all killed themselves because
they live with that thought of I could
have done that differently I could have
stopped it and that person might still
be here that's what you are living with
when you're working in the Combat Sports
now let me ask you a question because it
was intelligent like you dropped before
Rory McDonald at home we saw a busted
Mount we saw a busted [__] face
suddenly we saw a busted nose you know I
know he can't breathe I see the gulps
the whole thing you know you talking
about
coming into the fourth round
when you're sitting at any point do you
say yourself maybe I should just not
going to stop this oh I don't know what
the [__] is good these [__]
don't know you know uh uh you're there
you're there with me I
go to Oogie knocking me and I land on
one knee and we have I still have the
underhook under you and you throw a knee
or something and you see me go up and
you see it hit my larynx or something
you the people at home just see it as a
strike you know what's going on right
now he's you know little things like
that have you ever thought oh trust me
this [__] guy because he's getting
hit in the head he doesn't even know
what the [__] he's gonna feel like
tomorrow right now maybe I should just
you know that there's there's all kinds
of things that are out there and you
know people can they can think what they
want I'll be totally honest with you my
wife's sitting right here she's going to
know what I'm talking about but you know
there's there's fights I get people all
the time you know especially from the
early days I used to tell Fighters all
the time look at if you you get hurt you
need me to get you out of the fight tell
me I'll get you out of the fight I'll
take the blame you know and I would I'd
stop to fight you know referee stoppage
and people say you're an idiot for
stopping that he was doing this and
you're right you got it yeah I'm an
idiot you you know but it was the it was
the actual fighter saying I'm done I
can't go any farther and I'd stop it and
I said referee stoppage TKO I wouldn't
say he would tap out I wouldn't say
there was a verbal and I used to do that
and then it got to the point where you
know the sport changed to the point
where you couldn't really do that but
you know there are fights out there Paul
blunt
and krill was he was called Baby Fedor
you know and I use this fight when I
teach now you know too because I did the
fight it was an Affliction too and you
know Krill was supposed to be the next
big thing coming up and Paul buontello
was just beating the dog [__] out of
Creole sadilnikov he was hitting him
with a jab it was a stiff jab and he did
it from round one into round two into
round three where cadilla was cut all
over he was having problems and I could
see the problems but he's from Russia
he's Tougher Than Hell his Corner
doesn't give a [__] they they're going
to send him out for the end and it gets
to a point where
I have a little signal with my doctor I
stop it for a mouthpiece coming out I
call time I bring him over the doctors
so the doctor can check but you know I
give the doctor a signal which is
telling him we're stopping the fight
okay and now I'm gonna use the doctor to
be my guy to stop the fight because you
know everyone looks at the doctor as the
doctors are smarter than John McCarthy
and that's good they probably are okay
but if John McCarthy had just jumped in
and waved his hands people would have
gone no you know and thought I was an
idiot but if the doctor comes up and
looks at him and goes you know no I
can't go and I just turn around with my
hand the fight's over everyone's they're
good with it you know and even in that
fight the commentators look you know and
at the you know the you know doctor
comes up and they're saying oh the
doctor's looking you know yeah you know
what yeah that was a good good decision
by the by the ringside position to stop
that fight Krill had had enough it
wasn't the doctor it was me but I sell
it off a different way because it makes
it more palatable to the you know 14 000
people that are there they see they
can't hear anything they don't know but
they see the doctor and they go there
must be something a lot worse than I
know okay our whole job is to look at a
fight and try to let the fighter manage
his way through it but if they are
absorbing so much damage that they can
be damaged for the rest of their life
with what's going on our job is to get
them out
when I
went to the GSP John fitchfucker
and I went down the wrong way with Eddie
me Eddie and Oliver went down the wrong
way and ended up being in front of the
ambulance and they put jellyfish in
when they wheeled them towards me I
cried I cried like a manly I [__]
cried I couldn't believe that
he had this beaten like and GSP didn't
look that up CSP didn't look that good
either he was walking around he was a
champion but he was [__] hurting I
couldn't imagine that I went home to the
hotel that night and I was like I don't
even want to eat dinner
these I can't imagine that those are all
the things that you know what every
every week you're dealing with because
you know you look at you know GSP how
many times did he actually fight 27 30.
okay that's how many times before you
know if that that's how many times he
actually fought I do 27 to 30 fights you
know in the month easy and I've been
doing it for 22 years so you know those
are the things you look and you know I
deal with this all the time and I deal
with guys and you know what is occurring
in the sport and our whole job is to you
know become more evolved as far as what
we do and our job is to if we understand
that a Fighter's in trouble
take care of the fighter sometimes you
can't sometimes they're in that position
where they're actually you know in the
in the fight to the point where you've
got to let them go you know there's
there's a lot of things that I'll think
about you know when I have a fight going
on and you know part of it is you know
in my mind does the fighter have the
ability to win this on the cards you
know now I don't know what the cards are
but I have a pretty good idea if he's
been getting his ass kicked no he
doesn't okay what's best for the fighter
what's best for the sport what's best
for the fans but what's best for the
fighter always overrides the other two
and you've got to you weigh those things
out at times and then there's times when
you're going to let a guy go
because he has won this fight up to this
point he has been winning this fight you
know that on the scorecards this guy is
he's ahead this is the fifth round of a
five round fight you know that he's won
at least three of them easy
and he's in trouble now you're gonna let
him try to ride it out because hey he
does have a chance of winning this
but you will not let it ride out to the
point where what's the best for the
fighter at this point if he is not in
that position where they are fighting in
a competitive or intelligent manner at
that time it's time to get him out
this has been the most shocking I almost
got sick you know Miss Mack I almost
passed out before I looked at you he was
talking about blood and [__] I had to
start breathing out of my [__] nose
hey we weren't going to talk about MMA
right no let me uh give some shout outs
here you're in a rush Miss Mack no all
right hold on one second will apostolos
the Greek JB Beason Alex castino
Henry Henderson good to meet you last
night over at Bakersfield my man Mikey
Stein a one by one podcast Heisenberg
ookie spooky Andre Silva
the Australian Warrior my main man down
under
I don't know what the [__] this is over
here but I'll catch you tomorrow when I
figure it out then
what's up with you Lee
this is an education yeah it's amazing
guys I'm sorry I didn't say much for a
long time I was just recovered I really
was I was like hike the lumbar they're
between rounds when you were talking
about blood and stitches and going down
his [__] lungs oh my God I almost
passed that you know I'm really pumped
all that stuff there now we're gonna
switch it up for middle of May because
this is Iowa oh my God you [__] blew
my mind and I haven't set a peek since
our phone call as you know the hottest
show in America if you're over uh maybe
34 right now the people versus O.J
Simpson I [__] love it first off I'm
a law freak any Law and Order is that's
my [__] loan on SVU I can't watch
because of the rape and [__] I can't
tolerate it so I don't even put that
[__] on I don't have the stomach for all
that woman too much sometimes it
destroys me as Vu but Law and Order
straight up I will watch it for the
trial and sit there and take notes at
two in the morning like an [__] you
know me dog so when this came up I
wasn't gonna watch it but I worked with
somebody and they said that
they had shot this series
and when it comes on make sure you watch
it the people versus OJ says I don't
want to watch that before I lived it
there you go and they're like
they're like this is what was going on
behind the scenes and the racism and all
the
time and then I called John McCarthy and
he just squashed me he just said listen
[__] you [__] racing [__] all this [__]
all right this is exactly what happened
and when you said it to me it made all
the sense in the world because I've been
watching all those shows lately about
the football players and you know so
what was your take on this whole thing
after six episodes let's cut through the
chase well I mean as far as the show you
know the TV series my wife hates it you
don't like him now why what's your
problem she lived through it right you
lived through it you lived through it
once you live through it
you know the whole point is this you
know
I I'm not I'm not big in the race I mean
I don't give a damn if someone's purple
okay you [__] up you [__] up that's it
that's it that's it you're either a good
person you're a bad person okay I don't
the color of your skin your you know
your religion you know where you come
from I don't give a [__] be a good
person you know I'll be your friend be
an idiot and I'll be your worst enemy
that's you know just the way I look at
life but
you know that whole thing with OJ is
when you know in watching it you know
you look at everything that occurred
with it and you know you know
straight out you know not a doubt OJ did
it okay he got away with it he got away
with it because of lawyers and because
of people you know that at the time kind
of wanted to prove something I think in
a way I don't know but when I look at it
you know back when I was on LAPD they
they brought the pictures of
Nicole Brown
at Simpson and Ron Goldman brought him
up to us because we were supposedly the
experts in uh they're saying hey what
what what would do this you know how big
of a knife and I remember looking at
them you know the autopsy photos of her
and and the actual crime scene photos
that were and I mean he did a number on
her if you look at it and uh there was a
lot of violence there and there was
violence with Ron and you could see
defensive wounds on his hands and there
was a there was a couple that was you
know his eye on one of his eyes he had
been poked twice you could see with a
knife and it was you know why because
someone was seeing if he was still alive
you know they said why why would that be
there because the he thinks that he's
still alive so he's poking him to see
that he's not
you know
and so I you know you look at this and
you know and I'm I'm the first one to
tell you you know back I was an O.J
Simpson fan I mean I was a huge fan from
when you know when I was growing up
Monday nights
when he was playing for SC you know I
was always a Notre Dame fan but I loved
O.J Simpson you know and so it was okay
if OJ beat you know Notre Dame and then
you know he goes to the pros and you
know the 2003 or whatever it was season
or whatever I can't even remember
let's say 2000 2003 yards not the season
whatever year it was that he did that I
mean I was a huge fan I even you know as
an LA police officer I stopped you know
I was on a stop that he was part of and
stuff and you know because he was the
O.J Simpson you know I was you know hey
man you're gonna let him go man that's
the juice
but I look at it now and you look at
what's come out in football and you look
at what's you know in fighting and
traumatic brain injury and the CTE that
has you know come about and you have the
show concussion that Will Smith just did
the movie if you know you have an idea
deal what's going on but all these
football players Junior Seau taking his
life and Dave duerson taken his life and
Andre Waters taking his life all with
these problems of anger depression all
of these things that we now know come
from all of these repetitive hits to the
head all these things that O.J Simpson
had for all of those years and
throughout his high school and college
and then all the years of being a pro
football player and he's close to 14
years as a pro
he fits into the perfect category of
this is a guy that is suffering from CTE
and you look at the Timeline you know he
he retired from football in 1980.
and this happened in 1994. 14 years
later take a look at what's going on
with these guys and when they're having
problems you know I'm not saying it you
know takes away from what he did it was
you know absolutely horrible it should
never happen but I think you know when
you look at OJ now from what I hear OJ
being in jail he's like a child he has
problems with memory he doesn't remember
anything he doesn't understand why he's
there at times and all of those things
are exactly what you're looking at with
a guy that has CTE which explains that
loss of control and that loss in that
Rage of what could lead to this one
incident I mean how many [__] times
does the cops go to that house
quite a few she had 660 some different
because when when you said that to me
last week you know when this went on I
was going through my own divorce so I
was thinking of killing that [__]
myself and this just fed into my [__]
fire didn't stand me I mean I'm dead I
was going through Alan bold on it with a
child in the middle and then it was just
it would get worse and worse and you
know money and we've just you know but I
I followed it like how can this guy do
this who would I mean as soon as I saw
the paper I knew it was him that's that
whatever that Monday morning when I woke
up in Boulder and I saw it I had heard
like years later he beat it one night
and I just put two and two together I'm
just you know ah dude I'm telling you
right now I was one of the dummies and
let him go okay anyway back in like 19
and I loved him as much as you I loved
him as a kid I mean he was everything
you know I didn't want to believe it but
then but when you see the horror of it
yeah listen even you shoot somebody in
the leg
you know what that he shoots somebody or
something there's a big difference
between shooting someone and using a
knife and using a knife
had this and this so I didn't know if
there was two people involved you know
then I got that cut in the hand
and I know that whenever you do anything
for my criminal days no matter what you
do
something always cuts and you don't feel
it because you're adrenaline is going
absolutely you don't feel it to an hour
away though Jesus I need to my hand I
was hanging from a barbed wire one time
with two cops and the dog chasing me and
you know I ran all the way home like
nothing
I didn't know until I went to take the
glove off that they needed stitches and
the whole thing I didn't know but my
adrenaline got you there so you know you
get into a fist fight in this street
yeah you get hit in the head you don't
even know you got them you bleed from
yet what happened what are you talking
about oh [__] so I believe in you know
something especially when you use a
knife like because the knife slips
it's not even that you know he's he's
grabbing a hold and he's you know if you
saw the thing there was there was
multiple you know he had there was a lot
of punctures which are straight out
stabs and there was a lot of slashes you
know and he slashed her across I can't
remember if it was left or right but it
was this giant gash that went from
almost her collarbone down here straight
up to her ear I mean and it it obviously
the power behind it because it you know
it cut her trachea all the way through
it cut her all the way to the spinal
cord you know to her certain you know
cervical spine so I mean there was a lot
if you're looking at it you go you know
that was a strong human being a lot of
people were saying well he's an older
man no he's you know look at you know I
don't care if he's old or not he is a a
he was an incredible athlete very strong
and you know he could do that kind of
thing you know you know unfortunately
you know
we learn things as time go by and I
don't know you know for sure if you know
this whole thing with CT is what
happened you know and he had it but I
would bet that that was the thing that
made him as far as depression on her
being with someone else and just that
rage that you lose it and because your
brain has lost the ability to utilize
you know Common Sense and that rage
builds and it goes because your brain
has been altered there is a disease
inside of it it's based upon what he did
for a career in football it seems like
the one of the defensive main points is
that the cops didn't like continue an
investigation they just focused down
okay now here's the thing what as a cop
if you have what they thought was a slam
dunk case
are you still going around like looking
for something even though we have the
guy here but we still have to like look
around the corner you know you can look
you can go back and look at that whole
thing and you know this is what they had
let's as simple as it gets you've got
you know two victims that were attacked
brutally okay you've got Nicole said you
got Nicole's blood you got Ron Goldman's
blood
O.J was cut
on the finger but you know let's not say
that we even know it's him so we have
Nicole's blood and Ron's blood at the
scene we have O.J Simpson who's got a
Bronco that is seen leaving the scene
but the person went and did the story so
they didn't use them in things but it is
seen they go to the his house there's
blood inside of his Bronco that is the
blood of
O.J Simpson Nicole Brown Simpson and Ron
Goldman now O.J Simpson wasn't a friend
of Ron Goldman didn't know wrong goals
why would Ron Goldman's blood be inside
of his Bronco
doesn't make sense
if you in his house in his washing
machine he had all three Bloods that
were in the washing machine why were the
why were they in the washing machine
because he's washing the damn clothes
that he did what
right he
in his bathroom there's all three Bloods
inside now if you want to sit there and
think this is the part that I love you
know it was a police conspiracy let me
make this as clear as I can for you okay
I was a police officer and there's not
freaking two of them that can hold a
story okay to sit there and think that
the police conspired against O.J Simpson
this person that was this here's an icon
at the time okay doing all the different
things in the movies the sports you know
Hertz rental car commercials all that
stuff and you're going to get these
lowly police officers that are going to
conspire to try to
say that he did something when there
could always be something coming out
saying no here's the truth boom which
only puts them in jail
all right yeah sure the police conspired
to do it because police are so good at
you know sitting there and holding on to
this little secret and they're gonna do
it it's the most ridiculous
thing that anyone could ever go with
policemen are the first ones to roll on
each other you'll get doctors you'll get
lawyers that sit there you know police
officers roll on each other all the time
and you say everyone says oh there's
that blue you know that Thin Blue Line
[__] okay doctors if I'm a doctor
and I know that Joey's a doctor and he
sucks as a doctor and someone asks me
yes he's a doctor I don't sit there and
roll and I'm saying that he's doing
crooked stuff or anything like that I
just let it go lawyers you know they
don't sit there and roll on each other
no one rolls on each other like police
officers but police are going to sit
there and try to conspire to put O.J
Simpson in jail for a double murder sure
just [__] nuts it was intro it was
interesting watching it
I it kind of to me seem like Blackjack
where I learned like we at first you
think you're trying to get to 21 but the
whole one is to like have the dealer
bust like though you're just trying to
beat the dealer
the thing with the with the trial it
seems like
everyone's trying to beat each other but
the whole thing is just trying to get
the jury to think that maybe there's
another scenario so it didn't it didn't
even matter that the cops probably could
have never done that it's an education
there's no the way they did it they
passed off the blood they had tubes and
they took it home and they pulled into
another one and that's too much that's
too much listen there was One Bad Apple
I can understand but three guys all that
time and you know what man they got the
[__] Yankees against two regular
prosecutors they got the Yankees they
got five of the most powerful [__]
muslims-in-law to attack you like they
said you know this show is written but I
think it's written from like a lawyer's
perspective to highlight how the
attorney the attorneys Bluff these
[__] just you know just Bluff
them just Bluff them with magic tricks
it was just a bunch of magic tricks it
really was
you know the whole thing if you look at
it you go back and watch the trial first
off Edo was about as pathetic an
individual as you could get as a judge
okay he let stuff go you go you're an
idiot okay you know you as a judge
control that courtroom the same as a
referee controls a fight you're letting
people fight
but there comes a point you go knock it
off okay straighten your stuff out well
points boom whatever you're going to do
that's your job you're the referee of
this trial and he allowed just minutia
to go out there because he didn't want
anyone to go back and be able to say
that he didn't offer the ability so it
could go to an appeal look at a murder
case is always going to be appealed
that's just what happens especially if
you know someone that has the attorneys
that he has they're going to appeal so
what that's part of the that's part of
the process let them appeal your job is
to do things straight down the middle
and they gave a writer a front row seat
why would he do that why would he do
that
because he wanted to be famous it was
about lancito that whole trial became
this is my trial it's not your trial
it's the people's trial but you became
involved in wanting to be bigger because
of this thing no one gives a [__] about
you it's like being a referee no one
gives a [__] about John McCarthy it's
the two fighters that are important let
that be fair let me make sure they're
doing things right Let It Go
the decision came out like 10 o'clock in
the morning right 11 o'clock in the
morning
what was the [__] mood at the police
stations around oh we knew now you guys
knew going in already oh dude you know
every look at it it was his you know
look at he did it he's gonna get off
okay oh yeah there was not a doubt in
our minds we were going to be shocked if
they found him guilty at the time I
really thought they were going to find
them guilty like at that time I didn't
have any doubt in my mind that he was
gonna there was just too much [__]
evidence
there was just too much evidence I
thought
yeah there you know that you're looking
everything if you look at that trial you
know the one thing they didn't bring out
in this whole TV show is you know Gil
Garcetti was the district attorney for
city of Los Angeles okay and OJ that
crime where it was committed is in
Brentwood all right that's West Los
Angeles police as far as you know
division wise for the lap it's West LA
Division and
all those preliminary cases of
everything that happens in that area
goes to Santa Monica Court as far as
well it goes to First of West LA for
preliminary and then if it's found to go
to Superior Court which it would have it
would go to Santa Monica Court
but Gil Garcetti because he wanted his
face on TV all the time with this and he
wanted it present he moved it from Santa
Monica Court which is where it should
have been to downtown L.A it changed the
aspect of the jurors that we're going to
be part of it you know
OJ was a person that lived in Brentwood
you know those are the people that you
know should have been the ones that were
sitting on his jury but they went and
they moved it to downtown L.A so they
took the pool came from downtown LA
juror selection and that's what you got
and that's just politics of you know a
D.A looking at this like this is my
chance to really shine and to put myself
out there and to be on TV because now I
want to be mayor after this and this is
what he got for it
I felt so bad for uh Darden when he went
for the glove try I just didn't say oh
my God you look at that and it's like
come on the gloves were soaked with
blood okay so they're soaked with blood
first then they're put into testing by
the labs and so there's more fluid
that's being put on what happens to
leather when you put a lot of fluid on
it shrinks oh God you're a rocket
science I couldn't [__] believe it
either I couldn't [__] believe it
either I'm sitting there at home going
this isn't [__] happening and then
it's nobody and then it's not only does
it shrink you're gonna put a rubber
glove over someone's hand to try to get
it in there it's like the stupidest man
and if you watch the original not even
the TV one the original he's [__]
acting boy he's [__] acting oh I'll
be a good actor you gotta see it he's
acting and he's yeah
he's [__] going like this dude it
reminds me the best the best
representation I got of that was there
was a fight in Japan Bob Sapp was
fighting Jerome lebaner he was in in the
K1 organization and I was there to do a
fight and Bob Sapp and Jerome were going
to do this we're going to do kickboxing
in round one and MMA in round two and
then you know kickboxing three and MMA
in round four and it's gonna be this
four round fight and Bob Sapp almost
gets killed by Jerome in the first round
but he makes it through it and so then
they change the gloves from kickboxing
boxing gloves to MMA gloves and he goes
through the second round and he takes
Jerome down and he's mounted on Jerome
and he's hitting him with these giant
freaking Hammer gorilla fish he's doing
as he's doing his thing but he can't get
rid of him and it goes to the end of the
second round and so now they're gonna go
back to their corners and take the MMA
gloves off and put the boxing glove on
and Bob is I'm tired get me out of this
and he's got Sam Greco and Maurice Smith
in his corner and Sam's slapping him
going you're not quitting right Gibson
and they've got these four little
Japanese guys trying to peel the gloves
off his hands but then when they're
trying to put the MMA Bob saps doing the
OJ man is his displayed like this it
doesn't fit it doesn't fit right they're
trying to shove this boxing glove on his
hand he goes it does if it's too small
and it was like hey he's got the OJ
thing down perfect man
[__] Bob's oh he's awesome
bro always an education to have you on
here I'm blown away I was blown I didn't
know how the point system worked
I didn't know how they were seated I've
been confused that's why I don't talk
about it I don't really get involved in
it because I knew there was a by the way
involved in this whole [__] thing
with the judges I didn't know for sure
you know I was under the impression that
but I knew I couldn't be that stupid and
I know the commissions couldn't be that
stupid I was on the impression that you
just raised your hand they put you
through like a little training yeah you
sit and then you talk to them for 10
minutes and there they are yeah and
that's why all these bad [__] calls
or whatever people think like I said if
you get beat up it's there it's all in
the cards I don't know I don't [__]
know Julie I have no idea I have no idea
look at the shape of [__] week what's
next for you my big brother for me you
know I'm just uh busy I'm gonna be uh
working here for going to uh what's the
Philippines coming up next week so I go
there to do a fight so I go to Italy I
go to uh all over I'll be I'll be doing
like five different six different shows
and
uh April here and just having a good
time I just I'm just lucky I get to do
what I do do you look good you're
healthy Mrs Mac you go to Philippines
though she's going with me okay all
right cost me money every goddamn Hey
listen the Philippines you got those
little pigs but you gotta eat the
pigeons
You Gotta Eat the pigeons with the
little foot sticking out it's still
clucking in there you gotta eat it it's
half alive lumpia that's what they call
it right Lou I know that what's that one
called Balu Balu yeah they got a bunch
of weird [__] down there you got to take
shots to go down there no no I don't
have to take shots to go down there
they're the nicest people man nicest
people man I mean they're so nice family
oriented Yep they're great worst traffic
in the world we even worse than La Man
by far oh you've been there before oh
yeah okay multiple times but yeah it's a
it's a great place but great people man
that's horrible traffic how's the food I
love the food there I love you eat
monkey and all that [__] don't be
[__] there's no reason to eat monkey
dude you see the monkeys there hell yeah
dude
if I saw a [__] monkey in the street
Miss Mack like hanging like that you
could I die I would die to see somebody
like a monkey remember Faces of Death
When We Were Young oh yeah remember they
broke the monkey's head
will you ever watch faces at that video
no I'm not gonna watch your face it's a
little Hannibal Lecter thing man [__]
craziness they took a monkey and they
put them in the table and they had his
head was out
just beat him in the head with the
[__] hammer and then you eat his
brains or something like that one of
these foreign countries you win I'm out
I think they do it over at Magnolia
where you get those tacos over those
lizard [__] tacos every restaurant I
go to he has a different animal that I'm
eating this here he has been convinced
there's a lizard taco place the
dumplings are made of cats
listen
Emilia Rivera told you last week that
what was the percentage you said of of
uh [__] up meat is found in L.A at the
restaurants I even have a percentage
when they get tested he ain't
bullshitting and he picked your arrest
around that way nobody [__] dumplings
down there you come back with a
different look on your face tell me that
you're dead no they might no his dad
came from Floyd took him for those tacos
I said take him for a nice burger or
trout burger no no he takes up the tacos
the lizard tacos the guy's home for
three days [__] blood you can't
leave the [__] house I gotta take him
for like comedy what'd you take them for
where they put the thing of coffee in
his ass with uh
you took your dad for a colonic yeah
what kind of dude that's just gonna go
to the bathroom for four days
that'd be weird
[Laughter]
give me some paperwork the show's always
sponsored by on it I love these guys
I'm waiting on my new shipment of the
Dolce protein I don't even know don't
you had don't chase like the man of a
thousand things going on he's doing
jumping jacks he's making his own
[__] protein dude he's got cookbooks
I love the things you cannot take it
away no no he's on Twitter at eight in
the morning pushing deadlifts people on
there what should I do for cardio
deadlifts you [__] that's a deadlift
squats squat till you die squat do you
die anyway you no no he's got some stuff
going on with on it so before we talk
about him and away from my shipment but
you know me I live on the shroom Tech I
live on the Alpha Brain I even had to
give my wife a couple [__] Alpha
brains yesterday she gave me Apple Juice
by mistake with sugar in it or something
she thought it was [__] green tea I
go where'd you have that it was right in
front of you I just gave it to the baby
the baby likes apple juice but uh you
know honors always it always works for
me not right now but it always usually
the go to on it web page and see the
great new selection of proteins and
supplements they have right now go down
calm you like anything go to the box
impression Church boo
c-h-u-r-c-h [__] and get 10 off
your next order all right number two let
me talk to you people about something
you know me I'm a man of many seasons
but from time to time you know me I
drink a little red wine
do I know what the [__] I'm drinking not
really you come to my table and you're
going you know you want PA called Dan
1684 I don't give a [__] what it is just
kidding because I don't know what it is
I just drink a little wine I get Hammond
I don't drink but I enjoy wine and if my
wife has it with dinner whatever but
again what's the toughest thing after a
long exhausting day all you want to do
is sip a glass of wine and relax but
unless you plan the head you probably
don't even have a bottle of wine in your
house you already spent enough time
winding through the grocery store
looking for bottles you don't know what
to drink you're calling your friend he's
not answering the phone you know you get
lost in the wine out you just end up
picking a bottle based on the labor you
don't really even understand your bird
yeah Thunderbird you go home you open
you realize it's like a Chardonnay as
much as you thought it you don't like
Chardonnay as much as you thought all
right what I'm trying to say is this all
right go to Club W with Club W you never
have to worry about being wine free
again you know people like to go home
crack a bottle of wine this is you it's
a revolutionary new wine club that sends
you wine directly to your door saving
all those trips to the grocery store not
only does Club w send you wine they send
you the wine that you'll love drinking
Club W has a six question quiz figures
out your palette so every bottle you
receive you is perfectly tailored for
your taste who does that shitly okay
Club W is the leading grape the glass
wine Revolution they work directly with
The Vineyards and they cut out the
middlemen okay which saves you what get
us money that's right Club W even offers
you a no risk guarantee that you'll love
right you're gonna love what they send
you you take that little quiz they even
send you recipes to eat with that wine
they send you listen if you're a Momo
like me about wine this is for you do me
a favor why [__] around go to Club W
right now I'm offering all my listeners
50 off your first order 50 not 10 not 20
50 off go to clubw.com Joey right now
and I'm giving you 50 off don't ever
come home to a wine free house again
okay just go to clubw.com
Joey and you get 50 off your first order
all right you heard me right
clubw.com Joey
another one of my favorites here you got
me on these at your house yeah I gotta
get you hooked up with me you have me on
these numbers
tremendous
sorry about that
you're gonna get a little water here
I mean these are the only underway I use
for jiu jitsu
they're good for jets because when
you're fat that the thing falls off the
underwear you crack you're trying to do
a [__] on my Plata your [__]
sticking out who needs that aggravation
so what I'm trying to say is this I love
weird listen whether you're wearing
suits or sweats you spend 24 hours a day
in your underwear but instead of making
a statement like Superman's tight under
his everyday clothes you're probably
wearing underwear that are boring
they're white they got streaks in them
they smell like [__] death well
listen man this is here to to change all
that right prepare me on these is made
from a substantially sourced Mo dog
m-o-d-a-l right
m-o-d-a-l I'm sorry a fabric that's
twice as soft as cotton nothing can
describe the FIT and feel of me on these
but once you try them you understand why
they're called the world's most
comfortable underwears and if you don't
love your first pair me on these guess
what get us free no questions asked me
Andy says dozens of styles limited
edition prints that come out every month
and you can make a statement and [__]
you bring some freak home you take your
pants off bam there you are looking like
a bella figure anyway
that's right do me a favor shipping is
free in the U.S and Canada and you save
up to eight dollars a pair with a me on
these subscription plan so do me a favor
get the subscription or get the single
pair you get 20 off your first order
when you go to me on these.com slash
Joey just go to meanddies.com Joey read
all about look all uh at the cotton
underwear in the cotton the mobile
underwear they have look at all the
Styles and all the stuff they have
available t-shirts and sweats and
whatnot so do me a favor go to
meandis.com Joy for 20 off your first
order that's beyond these.com slash Joey
I want to call next week I'm going to
Paducah this week but the week after I'm
at home all week I love to come on the
bus you can come on my podcast yeah I'm
gonna come up here because I got to go
to tell me when you're ready
I gotta do something like that Tuesday
like at seven in the morning
Rico and [__] Mumbo I gotta do radio
so I'm up there ready going that's all
right so I have a few tacos that's a
nice taco neighborhood and right from
there I shoot up to your place do you
what are you tape it I most of the time
I tip it right in my place okay the
other guy's just way out in Kansas but
it's it's all right there you go man and
I'll take you out on the boat we'll go
out look at some ocean no no I guess
seasick maybe we gotta go look at some
whales and dogs let me tell you
something I don't know what happened I
went swimming a couple months ago and I
wanted a plane that [__] up my ears
and I've been getting cars sick but it's
hereditary because the baby I can't take
them nowhere I could take it locally if
I take them in the car and we go for a
little ride she gets car sick all of us
have it so we got to go on that
Dramamine [__] that's no good when this
last week I've gotten costing three
times all downhill
not uphill I don't know what the [__]
going on I got sick on the way down
Laurel Canyon on the way down from
Bakersfield down uh
I got sick last night and I got 60 a day
going into town on Laurel Canyon but
it's always downhill so if something's
going on when I'm sitting like this I
gotta get like a [__] straight car or
something like figure it out [__]
John McCarthy I love you Mrs Mack
looking better than ever with the
[__] head through look at you John
McCarthy moving out the [__] out of
here look at you he's Savage Lee what
are you gonna do sit there and stare at
me everything all right over there
everything's great what's going on with
you tonight we going out sure let's do
it we got Ari shafia's storytelling show
you coming down there tonight hell yeah
all right
you all right I'm doing good all right
thank you for listening to the church
we'll be back Tuesday night don't forget
about us stay black have a great day God
bless you have a great Monday do you
want to just end with uh I want to be
around and I want to be around Tony
Bennett you bad [__]
just like that Lee
what do you think you're dealing with
Joey bananas
thank you
it's twice as smart
laughs
[Music]